Australia is set to buy at least three
U.S manufactured nuclear submarines at a
cost of 245 billion dollars that could
eventually increase to five submarines
amid growing concern around China's
influence in the indo-pacific region
announcement was made as U.S President
Joe Biden hosted the prime ministers of
Australia and Britain in California John
hendren reports from Point Loma naval
base in San Diego
it is a bold effort to shift the balance
of power in the Pacific the leaders of
the U.S the UK and Australia cementing a
plan to deploy nuclear-powered
submarines from the Australian coast our
unprecedented trilateral cooperation I
believe is Testament to the strength of
the long-standing ties of Uniteds
and to our shared commitment of ensuring
The indo-pacific Remains free and open
prosperous and secure the plan will take
decades to complete the defense alliance
called August has already begun with the
first of hundreds of Australians
embedding in U.S and UK submarine
building programs more U.S Subs will
start visiting Australia this year while
British Subs will increase rotations
from 2026 by 2032 Australia plans to buy
three nuclear-powered Subs containing
Conventional Weapons from the U.S with
the option of buying two more and
sometime in the 2040s Australia expects
to have its own nuclear sub built by the
UK and Australia using U.S technology
the orcus agreement we confirm here in
San Diego
represents the biggest single investment
in Australia's defense capability in all
of our history the biggest threat in the
Pacific comes from an increasingly
aggressive China which has built new
fortifications in the South China Sea
it's a situation China has
has created and brought upon itself very
much like Russia has in the Ukraine
China's Xi Jinping has called the August
plan an effort to encircle and contain
his country
the USS Missouri here is a
nuclear-powered virginia-class attack
submarine the kind the U.S will send to
Australia is that country develops the
capacity to build its own nuclear subs
go longer farther and faster than
conventional subs and that's a big
advantage
the new Fleet replacing Australia's
aging diesel Force requires the U.S and
UK to boost their nuclear shipbuilding
capacity and to build one in Australia
from scratch but ultimately the defense
of our values depends as it always has
on the quality of our relationships with
others with China engaged in its own
submarine building program and flexing
its muscles in the South China Sea the
three English-speaking August nations
are betting that together they can
better counterbalance the size of
China's Naval Force John hendren Al
Jazeera San Diego
Let's cross now to Sarah Clark in
Brisbane Australia so Sarah how
significant is this agreement for
Australia in particular
well Anthony Albanese is described as a
new dawn for Australia's defense policy
as mentioned it's the largest defense
acquisition in Australia's history with
a cost of about 245 to 250 billion
dollars over the next three decades now
I should note that this deal was a first
announced under the last prime minister
Scott Morrison but that does mean
there's bilateral support in federal
Parliament now the pitch to the
Australian audience that Anthony
Albanese is giving on this day is that
it will create around 20 000 jobs across
industry defense and public service now
we've talked about the first the three
American manufactured nuclear subs being
the first off the ranks but we're also
talking about Australia getting involved
in building these nuclear hybrid Subs
now construction for those will begin
and the design and development will
begin in 2023 and as mentioned they
won't be on the water we don't think
until the end of next decade or 2040s
but the key reason and again the selling
point to the Australian audience from
the Australian government is that this
will boost defense intelligence sharing
capacity due to these three nations the
three navies sharing the same technology
it's also the government hoping that
this agreement act will act as a
deterrent to the increasing foreign
threats that we have in the indo-pacific
and of course he's referring directly to
China and it's encroaching military
presence across the Pacific well yes you
mentioned China there what about the
impact that this may have on Australia's
relationship with China
well the last hour or so the Australian
government has confirmed term that it
has offered a briefing to China but it's
yet to hear a response from Beijing but
China has been highly critical when the
fur the details were first released of
this trilateral security agreement they
said the deal constitutes serious
nuclear proliferation risks and it
exacerbates the arms race and it hurts
peace and stability in the region
they've also called for Australia the UK
and the US to abandon what Beijing calls
the Cold War mentality now of late we've
seen Anthony albelisi and Xi Jinping
have meetings on the sideline of the
talks G20 talks that was considered a
positive after a decade of a turbulent
relationship with China under the former
prime minister Scott Morrison so
certainly we do expect now with these
details of this orcas trilateral
security agreement release we do expect
a potentially another turning point in
that relationship but as mentioned it is
the largest defense acquisition in
Australia's history Sarah Clarke live in
Brisbane for us there thank you
well staying with this let's bring in
Andy monk now he's senior research
fellow at the center for China and
globalization he joins us from Beijing
welcome to the program so is this move
much of a surprise really given U.S
fears over a more assertive China
now and this unfortunately is not
surprising at all and I think largely uh
expected but that being said it still is
very destabilizing and I think further
Evidence uh of the US's uh anxiety and
fear about a peacefully rise in China
given what you say man what is China's
reaction likely to be then in the in the
medium to long term
well I think this only strengthens The
View uh that has been articulated by
presidency and tingfang the foreign
minister that if the U.S continues down
this path uh it raises the risk of
outright conflict and of course uh this
is not good for China but it's also not
good for the us as well as we all know
uh the U.S is economically intertwined
uh with China as are many other
countries around the world so uh these
destabilizing actions really are uh
counterproductive in many many aspects I
mean will military hardware alone be
enough for this orcas Alliance to
succeed in its goals
and that's such a great point so the U.S
is in a sense has one tool to play which
is uh or to use which is its military
but if we look at China's approach of
course it invests in is uh upgrading its
military capabilities but it is making
significant gains on the Diplomatic
front we need to look no further than
the recent uh Iran Saudi Arabia uh
rapprochement uh China's role in a
Ukraine peace plan uh initiatives in the
Pacific
um that's one very very important aspect
the economic aspect of course is very
important as China uh is offering an
increasingly growing and sophisticated
Market to countries all around the world
including the United States
um in terms of information as well I
think China we can see making advances
uh in this area uh perhaps the least
developed so far but certainly uh
advancing on all fronts it's whereas I
think the U.S is perhaps overly relying
on only a military uh approach to
dealing with its anxieties and fears
about China so how might this impact
other areas of relations between China
and these countries such as trade for
example will there be some overlapping
well I think certainly uh you know China
wants to have uh harmonious productive
bilateral relationships uh with
countries around the world and I think
for Australia and Great Britain this
certainly complicates matters and I
think especially uh for the United
Kingdom uh which historically at least
in recent years has not had a very
significant military role uh in the Asia
Pacific region so uh again I think this
is unhelpful and it's going to
complicate things
Andy Mark we very much appreciate your
time thank you
thank you for having me